What if everything you've been told
about living an extraordinary life is
precisely what's preventing you from
having one? The extraordinary life isn't
found in rare achievements, but in how
you experience ordinary moments.
Consider the regret minimization
framework. Imagine sitting with your
80-year-old self. What would they tell
you about today's decision? The Japanese
concept of eeky guy finds that sweet
spot where passion, purpose, and
livelihood converge. It's like having a
map when everyone else is just wandering
around. What if instead of building a
life that survives disruption, you could
create one that systematically improves
because of it? Anti-fragility goes
beyond resilience. It's like turning
what others see as poison into medicine.
In our distracted world, deep work is
becoming the ultimate competitive
advantage. It's the difference between
paddling in the shallows and diving into
the depths. The 8020 principle reveals
that 20% of your efforts create 80% of
your results. The extraordinary life
isn't about doing more. It's about
identifying your high leverage
activities. These frameworks don't just
add value. They multiply the
effectiveness of all others. Imagine how
different your life might be if every
decision were filtered through these
lenses.